بين الغرقه عثروا على جثه رضيع انتهى حلم
العشره بالعيش في اوروبا بالموت في مياه
المتوسط قبله سواحل مدينه كرتوني بكالوريا
الايطاليه ارتطم القارب الخشبي بصخور حطمت
امال من كانوا
من افغانستان وباكستان وايران وابحر من
ازمير التركيه باتجاه اوروبا السراب
الوهمي على حد وصفي وزير الداخليه
الايطالي تعددت واختلفت الروايات منذ
الحادث الماساوي بشان عددهم ارتفع عدد
القتلى اكثر من مره خلال اليوم انتشلت فرق
الانقاذ عشرات الجثث واستطاع نحو 80 شخصا
النجاه والوصول الى الشاطئ وانشمل بيان
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه اليمينيه جورج
ياميلوني جمله الحزن العميق بشان الحادث
فذلك لا يغير شيئا من القوانين الجديده
الصارمه التي تبنت لوقف تدفق المهاجرين
قالت ان الحكومه ملتزمه بمنع المغادرين
ومعهم هذا النوع من الماسي سنواصل القيام
بذلك يتطلب الامر قبل كل شيء تعاونا اكبر
من دول المغادره والمنشا استنادا لوزاره
الداخليه الايطاليه وصل الى البلاد اكثر
من 14 الف مهاجر منذ بدايه العام الجاري
مقارنه بخمسه الاف وثلاث مئه خلال نفس
الفتره من العام الماضي
ما حدث في كلابري يتردد صداه فيو مقر
البرلمان الاوروبي تحدثت رئيسيته روبرتا
ميتسولا عن حاجه الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
قواعد مشتركه ومحدثه تسمح بمعالجه تحديات
الهجره وضروره محاربته عصابات للتجاره
بالبشر الحقيقه ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لا
يدخر جهدا ومالا لمنع وصول المهاجرين الى
القاره العجوز للمفارقه في اجتماع الجمعه
الماضيه باثينا دعت خمسه عشره دوله في
الاتحاد الى تعزيز الحدود الخارجيه
لمواجهه تدفق المهاجرين وابرام اتفاقات مع
دوله ثالثه لاستقبالهم في نفس الاجتماع
قيل ان حدود اوروبا مفتوحه للمهاجرين
الاوكرانيين كما طالبت عده دول بما في ذلك
النمسا واليونان من الاتحاد تمويل اقامه
حواجز على الحدود الخارجيه لصد طالبي
اللجوء نقطه وصول كثير منهم هي عرض البحر
الابيض المتوسط مقبره بلا شواهد لمن
ارادوا ان يشهدوا حياه افضل وفي النهايه
ما تغرقا